welcome to this video new part of
opening disasters yeah this features the
philidor's defense a pretty solid
reliable opening that can be played by
the black player without any big
theoretical workload
however the philidor's nowadays is
reached by various move orders and very
rarely it is reached by the original
move order and in fact nowadays it's
pretty clear that the original Philidor
move order is not not really good and in
this game will also serve as yeah and as
an overview y e4 e5 Knight f3 d6 at
least in connection with the idea of
holding the center it's not a very
reliable opening what I'm talking about
is the following
d4 and now the only way really nowadays
to play this specific the specific move
order is to take this isn't entirely a
different animal than other versions of
the philidor's as here black is opening
up the center quickly and very often
tries to get counter play later by means
of Knight f6 Bishop e7 castles rook e8
yeah either I'm thinking about something
like this where for example castles
rupee eight something like that this is
a pretty decent setup for black it's not
like super active or anything but
something that you can easily play
however very often here like still wants
to get to the closed Philidor what I'm
talking about is something like this in
ninety seven ninety three ninety f6 this
specific position followed by something
like this this is also
very often caught the hen hem variation
named after some some person I think
from from the early 20th century or
maybe even earlier blacks ideas to just
hold the center and play c6 v6 a6 b5 a
slow Queen side a check and this is
pretty okay for like it's um it's it's
very much playable nowadays black
normally tries to reach that with this
move owner or alternatively this move 9b
d7 has one drawback it allows moves like
f4 or g4 which are really not bad if
I've can of course be answered by D
takes e5 and the Queen trade which is
entirely different thing but not
something that like really am should
fear very much if you want to play the
the close Philidor this is the the move
autumn that should be chosen so what is
the big problem with this move order the
issue is after deform if black wants the
closer the closed set up he can only
play two moves 97 or 96 if we start with
nine f6d takes e5 turns out to be a bit
awkward for black here D takes eve is
just blundering the whole thing and as
now this is a threat that costs you the
pawn on e4 at least white is going to
protect his pawn so the only way to play
is to capture only form and now White
has the somewhat problematic move Queen
to d5 just attacking this lone Knight
yeah if you've seen my first the first
part of the opening disaster series
remember maybe this idea the game that I
had with black against motwani here the
knight is not trapped it can move to c5
but now Bishop g5 Bishop e7
and takes Queen takes Knight c3 leads to
a position where lack is simply not
having a very attractive game white is
much better developed and black has some
coordination issues like castles castles
it's very difficult to play this
position for black and absolutely
unattractive because you have also AF
basically no chances to win and are just
worse long-term this is why Knight f6 is
out of business nowadays so what about
ninety seven this is the traditional way
to play this however it has a serious
problem and this is the move Bishop to
c4 this is clearly better than Knight c3
and something that white players should
be aware of Bishop c4 is a way to really
punish black here the relatively best
choice now is something that that is
very rarely played because the move
Knight d7 is really played with the
intention of setting up the close center
with c6 and so on the relatively best
move is to take on d4 now but if you
compare this with the capture earlier it
is clear that this makes far less sense
generally speaking because why put the
night on d7 in the open center the only
reason why it should be plated is that
the other moves are even worse yeah
let's start with simple things Knight f6
this is simply not going to work because
of 95 and you have this big issue what
else what a very often play miss Bishop
e7 which runs into runs into a famous
also famous refutation why it just takes
this is really really a good idea in the
Philidor as it frees the bishop here on
e7 however here it is justified by
concrete tactics takes it's a very short
day at the office
f7 is collapsing and if black takes with
the night
you exchange and play this threatening
f7 and e5 white is just winning a big
center pond with a good positional this
kind of stuff has been seen in in tons
of high-level games yeah with even some
grandmasters on the black site
so a very common a common mistake we
should be seven what else is there black
has to worry about 95 sometimes h6
astride however here white again can
take this time the refutation is a Isis
is similarly devastating if black know
takes with the pawn white has an
immediate immediate refutation by
checking on f7 very nice King takes 995
and here well we should move black has
no way to go this is track immediately
destroyed and that's this or this track
oh this Queen deform is a very very
strong refutation you can also a play
Knight c3 I believe if I remember
correctly I had looked at this ages ago
I think even this is possible just
getting another piece out and our
blackest is passed into a thinking on f6
this is Jack so I think entirely
impossible check check check check
yeah intent restless Restless carnage
yeah h6 mmm not possible
maybe we should okay we should briefly
look at this by the way check yeah also
famous way to have to lose quickly yeah
h6 is not not working so what else is
there there's really only see six what's
the idea of see six yeah
after Knight g5 now black can defend
with nine age six yeah covering f7 nc6
is of course also fitting within the
general structure that black is aiming
for however white still has a very
strong reply what he should do here is
to take and this is what when w did he
takes and now after Knight takes we meet
this thing again Jack black can play
Queen a5 check and hang on but this it's
very ugly yeah something like this
it's just leading to a position where
white has a huge advantage in
development and just a great game yeah
so they commonly play D takes d5 now
after after ninety five black needs to
cover with ninety h6 yeah and here when
the beard castles yeah here black
already has some trouble the knight on
age six is not very well placed and
black is also now in danger of losing
immediately and this happens after
Bishop e7 a very normal looking move and
this was played in the game by the way
and I should also mention that our
instead of taking white can also
consider to play and castles here first
in order to after Bishop e7 now go into
this line takes and 95
mmm this is also quite good because
Bishop takes Queen h5 gets the piece
back something like this is the
relatively best line like here or here
and here white enjoys the two bishops in
a semi open position yeah also quite
nicely not winning but nice yeah okay
this is what Mendel did and after this
now here Van bala the black player this
was played in the Netherlands 1983 by
the way just to put it into perspective
the black player now went Bishop to e7
yeah and this meets an immediate
refutation white now has the very nice
move you can try to find it yourself if
you want the very nice move last chance
to stop the video 96 96 very strong yeah
why is this strong yeah okay well you
need to take it I cannot allow any 97
businessö takes and now why it captures
on age six yeah and this is just a very
embarrassing situation black cannot take
the bishop and slack this is going to
lead into an immediate mate yeah it's
it's really quite quite quite nice as
this mate can only be covered with Queen
e8 and then you'll make have this nice
little mate it's absolutely devastating
black has has no decent move what he did
is Knight b6 played this in the game and
now white starts an immediate attack on
the king queen h5 check this is the
strongest move if black now plays g6 we
are just going to drop back to e to e
yeah
Black has a terrible power structure and
a bad King the relatively best
continuation is something something like
this maybe Queen and Queen here after
which White has a choice I think the
very simple move Knight
- is in fact good because it's difficult
for black now not to exchange Queens if
we look at the Queen trade at first you
might think okay well this is
disappointing shouldn't we make the guy
yeah maybe it looks like we should have
maybe one in the tech but the point is a
point is a point what we will get is we
will get the e5 pawn and this is such a
big advantage in the endgame that we
should win the game we don't need to
mate them all the time when we have a
promising attack
yeah well King f8 was played and
relatively speaking this is worse but
black of course was already in in big
big trouble
yeah how to continue now at first it
doesn't look that easy we have two
pieces hanging but white has a direct
refutation and then there will always
was and still is he plays a once in a
while a forceful player he played f4 f4
the most aggressive move it let's both
bishops hang but it is just doing this
what it needs to be done the fr needs to
be opened getting directly yeah towards
the king if black now takes one of the
pieces let's say it takes here we are
breaking through yeah so this is Jack
one point of the whole business and
black is destroyed if he takes here it's
Chen so check me not going to end well
so he cannot take both pieces he tried
the check first King h1 and now King to
g8 this is the relatively toughest
defense yeah how does wide now when
there's more than one way to do it when
the real now played f5 this is winning
he can also take him
yeah threatening Queen f7 after that
there's also no really defense for black
something like g6 Queen f3
is is going to be deadly like like this
now this is just too much like skiing is
a completely completely trapped and
white will just pile up on the F Island
and deliver some sort of blow on f7 of
f8 yeah he went f5 which is also very
convincing and even maybe a little bit
more spectacular black now took on age
six he also could have taken on c4 of
course after which why does some playing
f6 they are just very strong
if black now takes we can't play queen
g4 king of 787 and we just we just win
the house here yeah for example Jack
Jack something like that yeah white is
an exchange up here and of course we are
still attacking the king decisively yeah
he tried to take this but now F take c6
is really opening the floodgates whitest
everything in the tech now and he
threatens you seven Queen f7 of course
as well yeah he went Queen d7 and now
rook f7 was played which really is
decisive black tried this but now it's a
very simple made in Toulouse and after
rook evade jack found by a vendor will
of course black resigned the game yeah
it continues with this checkmate and the
nice little checkmate at the end so a
very quick win against against the the
Philidor and it shows that sometimes
pretty normal looking setups can be
problematic after Bishop c4 black
already is in some trouble it's really
not possible anymore to get a really
really good game now the only thing that
he can still tries to hang on with with
things
I can screen a five business you're like
like this Jack I can try it after after
this to avoid Bishop d7 of course he can
try and move like like this for example
but after something like Queen age five
but like really is not enjoying its life
very much if we consider this f7 hangs
what what is what is black smooth I
think it was the Queen e7 yeah just have
the smooth threatening this this Bishop
h6 that's not looking good and if you
Castle you have to at least very about
93 which puts you in trouble again
threatening Bishop h6 so black really is
struggling to get a good game after
White has found unknown the move Bishop
c4 also there the ton of possibilities
to win quickly
so why definitely should know and go for
this line against this this variation of
the Philidor very often you will win
quick and nice games okay thanks for
watching